and that's the problem with the world
the problem with the world is actually
weakening in I in no way shape or form
would ever allow it to come out of my
mouth that is women's fault it is weak
men that is letting these things happen
if we if men got together and said this
this promiscuity is [__] if men got
together and said hey we need to step up
and be stronger and be better that is
the only thing that I allow a woman to
actually let go so you may let him take
that masculine role the women hold on
and it's hard for women because they're
like [__] can this [__] do it can he
take care of me or is he gonna come home
and cry to me about his job no seriously